first US combat troops were sent to
Afghanistan way back after the 9/11
attacks and at one time there were
nearly a hundred thousand Americans
there the number now closer to 8400
Charlie d'Agata has reported extensively
on America's longest war and this
morning he is in the capital of Kabul
with the very latest charlie good
morning when you speak to Afghan field
commanders as we've done over the summer
they'll tell you three things they need
a lot more US forces they need them in a
hurry and they need them as close to the
front lines as possible in that regard
the speech left a few unanswered
questions as far as the official
reaction from Kabul this morning that
came from the office of President Ashraf
Ghani who said in a statement I'm
grateful to President Trump and the
American people for his affirmation of
support for our efforts to achieve
self-reliance and for our joint struggle
to rid the region from the threat of
terrorism from the time we spent with US
Marines and Helmand province
can you tell you some Authority they are
a long way from self-reliance 40 percent
of the country is falling to the Taliban
they are heavily dependent on us breeds
many who fought through the territory
that they were standing over that very
soil where so many American forces lost
their lives now under Taliban control
again the Taliban have weighed in to
saying they would continue their fight
as long as a single American soldier
remains on Afghan soil Gail thank you
Charlie d'Agata reporting from Kabul